There is however,
another way of thinking about
the tracking that I just showed you.
Let's not worry too much about
the mean shifting part of it and
just this idea of using
the color distribution as a,
the matching of the color distribution,
the similarity as a sensor model.
Okay?
Because when we do this mean shift and
we're tracking the single peak,
we're a little bit back to like
our Kalman universe, right?
Where the idea is there's
a single hypothesis.
We could just use this similarity
function, the matching function
of the color distributions as the sensor
model for particle filtering.
That is your particles spread out and
they want to say, well,
what's the probability
of getting this sensor
measurement if that's
actually the mice state.
Well, you can simply say, well,
it's just a measure of how close the
color distribution is using that body
chart distance of some other way
of comparing of distributions.
And in fact, people have done this and
now I have to show you
a totally unfair slide.
And the reason it's unfair
is this slide I found,
I was looking is in a presentation
given online, talking about mean shift.
I don't actually know the source of
this picture, so I can't give you the,
the reference to look it up, etc.
And then they show this
interesting thing where the mean
shift is tracking this cute little
kid and then falls apart, okay?
Now why would it fall apart?
This is a little bit sneaky.
You'll notice this brown envelope
cardboard box in the background.
It has some color distributions
similar to the face of the kid.
So, if you've ever thought little kids
are really, pretty much cardboard boxes,
you're right.
Or at least,
that's what mean shift says.
And then what they showed is that
if you used a particle tracker,
particle filter tracker,
it falls off a little bit.
See, it fell off, but
then it catches back on.
That's what particle filters do, right?
They entertain multiple hypothesis.
So, even if some weird hypothesis is
looking good as long as the real one
eventually becomes better,
it'll come back to it and
that's what its showing here.
But basically, the idea is you can use
the similarity function of the two color
distributions as your sensor model for
a particle filter.
And this relates to this idea
of what I said before that,
particle filters really
are pretty flexible.
You can pull out whatever sensor model
you want to use as long as you can put
it within this Bayesian
framework of p of z, given x.